j'ai découvert la vie de ceux qui ont
beaucoup dans cette vie j'ai appris tout
de suite à ne pas envier ceux qui ont
beaucoup beaucoup
après Loïc Le Floch Prigent Jenny Bel
Air donc vous allez faire des
révélations vous aussi Jenny sur la
République je tenais à dire quelque
chose merci beaucoup
celle-là tu l'as avec 10 points total
et avec des couverts
Jenny bonsoir donc François Jonquet vous
consacre un livre chez power qui
s'appelle Jenny Belair une créature vous
savez comment on fait
ça fait quoi d'avoir ça biographie dans
les librairies
je suis très très honoré pour mes
parents pouvaient quand même que recrue
c'est énorme bien alors créature c'est
quoi une créature c'est quelqu'un qu'on
aime quelqu'un qu'on comprend pas et
c'est quelqu'un qu'on déteste
cette créature d'épouvantable
cette créature Italie
alors je le dis pour Loïc qui a l'air de
beaucoup s'intéresser à vous vous êtes
travestis mais pas opéré
et vous dites
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup parce que vous détestez la
norme et c'est vrai que ce qui vous
intéresse en fait c'est d'être mi-homme
ni femme et pas d'être femme ou homme
avant tout c'est un être humain voilà
alors vous dites je ne m'aime que décalé
et vous dites quand vous parlez de vous
une femme ne mate pas autant le paquet
des hommes que moi
[Rires]
crevette là
[Applaudissements]
une femme arrive
toujours toujours
une femme elle se lève c'est comme ça
voilà alors on va parler de vous de
votre vie du livre qui vous est consacré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on vous appelle Jenny Belair on
vous a aussi appelé Françoise à cause de
Sagan on appelait la négresse la
la morue la morue
c'est l'humour quoi
votre vrai nom c'est Alain c'est faux
c'est faux quand même elle se
perds
parce que c'est pour la biopsie à la
visite médicale ça va être génial de
s'appeler c'est faux s'il vous plaît
alors votre père était condamné à mort
pour meurtre avec préméditation
dur il avait tué en fait le l'amant d'un
maquereau l'amant de sa femme c'est ça
oui il avait donc ce pas par rapport à
une crise de nerfs quand on est bafoué
et trompé et ben bon il a zigouillé et
puis le bagne oui parce que
sa tête donc il a été envoyé au bagne
l'île du salut où il a connu papillon
d'ailleurs
lequel papillon a un peu rajouté dans
ses mémoire vraiment énorme
et alors la libération quand de Gaulle
supprime le bagne votre père a le droit
de revenir en France papa doit revenir
en France et votre mère est d'origine
guyanaise vraiment est d'origine
guyanaise elle arrive dans cette France
merveilleuse liberté fraternité
negresses un regard
et tout de suite elle a subi le fameux
racisme rejeté etc donc ce qui fait
qu'elle a littéralement comme on dit
maintenant flipper
dépressive alcoolique elle vivait dans
des bars d'hôtel miteux tenus par des ex
bagnards elle-même avait été répudiée
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle avait été
tombée amoureuse du jardinier de son
père qui était un ancien bagnard alors
elle rencontre votre père à Paris vous
naissez en 53 et votre père devient lui
gardien d'Immeubles chic dans le 17ème
vous allez à l'école Saint-Ferdinand
avec votre avec votre frère et
finalement là vous découvrez la vie des
riches c'est à ce moment là dans le
quartier vous êtes déjà une petite reine
vous êtes déjà j'ai découvert la vie de
ceux qui ont beaucoup dans cette vie
j'ai appris tout de suite à ne pas
envier ceux qui ont beaucoup beaucoup et
il faut savoir après tout rester
donc vous êtes invité partout si vous
êtes déjà une petite star et même invité
chez Line Renaud parce que Sami votre
frère a sympathisé avec la famille dont
le chef de famille le père est chauffeur
de Line Renaud et vous bénéficiez des
largesses de Line Renaud pour les
pauvres vous établi par Emmaüs mais vous
vous retournez les vêtements pour faire
le clown quoi
pour retrouver une façon de vivre
autrement moi j'ai l'impression que vous
avez perdu votre micro
tu t'attarde pas non plus hein
[Rires]
pour mettre une pile quand même
ah ici ah là-bas allez
c'est pas payer à l'heure hein
mais au devoirs à celui-là alors bien et
là on rentre dans des choses un petit
peu moins rigolotes c'est-à-dire vous
êtes violé à l'âge de 9 ans par le
pédophile de la rue Denis poisson
étaient pas là j'ai commencé à me
tripoter c'est très très bizarre c'est
là où j'ai senti que le sexe peut-être
une douleur affreuse et un plaisir je
comprenais rien du tout je savais qu'il
faisait quelque chose de de sale je ne
voulais pas rajouter à mes parents mes
parents je pouvais pas parler de ça et
vous dites si je n'avais pas été abusé
pendant mon enfance je serai jamais
devenu Jenny Bel Air alors je serais
peut-être venu
d'Antillais bof gros avec des baignards
et des machins avec 56 maîtresses et
avec des actions
on a été comme Jenny
alors votre mère meurt de votre mère
meurt de chagrin de désillusion vous
êtes recueillis par la soeur de votre
père quand il vole et vous êtes dans un
petit village vous voulez comme vous
êtes une star de nature évidemment vous
devenez encore une fois la star du petit
village qui n'est grillon de service qui
fait marrer tout le monde quoi il y a
pas que ça c'est l'époque de la première
sodomie aussi oui
la
plus la plus la plus insensée je veux
dire que
quelques instants pour expliquer que
c'est comme si on était en poignardé la
lumière un peu quand même
par le regard
quand votre père meurt vous partez à la
DASS et là vous avez une adolescente un
peu clocharde un peu mais comme vous
êtes beau gosse ça se passe bien vous
faites l'incrus dans les boîtes à
Saint-Germain derrière le drugstore
nuage j'ai connu ça à l'époque hein
c'est bien mieux genre là on rentre dans
une époque évidemment qu'on a connu tous
les deux parce que le nuage ça commence
Jacques Chazot vous apprend la
conversation
Cyril lourdon a beaucoup appris aussi
par la suite et là vous devenez vraiment
Jenny Belair et puis un jour à l'âge de
je crois 18 19 ans vous êtes alors là
vous êtes interrogés par les flics un
interrogatoire assez musclé
prenez une gifle et vous réalisez d'un
seul coup si vous prenez conscience de
votre différence vous dites la société
de gifle parce que tu es une grosse
black habillée à la mormoy le
nœud et là vous vous dites ça y est là
il y a moi et eux c'est pas la même
chose ça y est les gens de pouvoir quand
ils veulent ils ne
sont pas la société vous met une baffe
voilà c'est ça dire que tes différentes
ma poule tu es donc où tu crèves ou tu
respectes ou alors tu te fais petit tu
rentres dans le vice et c'était terrible
grand moment grand moment donc dans la
piscine vide des Bains Douches
avant qu'il mette des tables sur la
piscine pour gagner plus d'argent il y
avait une piscine au bain douche et une
densier ou chantier dans la piscine des
bains de minuit et le garçon qui était
avec vous c'est geek webas Carion qui a
été dit jockey au sein au Palace
par accident Guy avait mis au nuage donc
je passais hop ça a été très très vite
33 40
70 45 et j'ai fait le gars comme ça
alors vous devenez Gazoline alors
Gazoline faut savoir ce que c'est
Gazoline c'est la fraction folle du
gauchisme c'est-à-dire à l'époque au
début des années 70 il y avait ce qu'on
appelait le phare le front homosexuel
d'action révolutionnaire qui était donc
des révolutionnaires quoi et il a
grande idée c'était d'aller crier
dans tous les endroits donc par exemple
un jour elle rentre au Flore et à
ce moment ils ont cru que j'étais
allemand quoi
il y avait pas que ça quand même c'était
j'étais récupéré par un groupe muscul
alors Aldo c'est un je sais pas comment
on peut dire un bordel de travesti de
transexuel qui servait surtout pour les
équipes de rugby et les pompiers chacun
a son vice ben oui chacun
et puis après il y a eu 7 alors le 7 rue
Sainte-Anne ceux qui ont connu le 7
évidemment non c'est déjà Fabrice et mer
qui était le patron il y avait Yves
Saint Laurent avec sa bande il y avait
Bowie la gare fell Naomi Campbell enfin
toutes les tops modèles de l'époque de
neuf et puis il y a beaucoup de coco
aussi il faut dire la vérité
il faut avoir connu le bal vénitien
organisé par Karl Lagerfeld
Jenny arrive sur une gondole parce que
c'est balvénients
de Paris vous étiez la reine de la
soirée qu'elle avait vu d'autres étaient
médusés en vous voyant c'est
extraordinaire et vous dites en parlant
de ça de cette soirée là vous êtes
arrivés sur la gondole vous dites jamais
je ne me suis sentie autant femme que ce
soit là c'était votre sacre d'une
certaine façon
j'ai vu tous ces gens qui avaient
tellement la mode tout ça tous ces gens
qui a dû qui était dans un qui me
regardait qui me regardait comme ça et
ben alors voilà je rentre pas dans la
famille mais il me relook
malheureusement malheureusement un
jaloux vous bouscule vous tombez je
tombe alors là pour dire encore parce
qu'on est très franc mais rognons sont
Schneider sont arrivés devant tout le
monde c'est à dire que comme ça par
terre et ils ont vu que j'étais doté de
circonstances voilà donc là vous êtes
physio effectivement au Palace vous me
permettez de virer Michael Douglas un
soir c'est-à-dire pas moi ça va me
laisser rentrer mais c'est bien faut la
remercier maintenant parce que il y a
quand même des stars qui sont fait
refouler à l'entrée vous avez une
définition formidable pour le Palace
vous dites c'est la plus longue fête de
l'histoire du monde je crois que c'est
assez juste oui je suis une très bonne
définition et puis après voilà bon après
il y a eu le sida il y a eu la fin du
palace la mort de Fabrice et mère
et vous dites ouvrir le palace
aujourd'hui ça serait comme ouvrir les
grilles du Père-Lachaise la nuit on
danserait dans un cimetière quoi les
personnes qui auraient envie de rouvrir
c'est une descente totale je crois que
il faut laisser les choses se faire
par la joie la douleur et de ceux qui
c'est moi je ne pourrais pas vraiment y
pénétrer rentrer dedans ça m'est
impossible et l'amour dans tout ça quel
amour
vous dites je n'ai jamais été aimé
vous dites j'ai entendu deux fois je
t'aime et encore la deuxième fois je
suis pas sûr ça a été vraiment sincère
etc parce que
ouais parce que je préfère entrer ou je
connaissais des gens etc mais le côté
j'ai jamais entendu ça jamais vous alors
ce que vous voulez c'est du bourgeois
c'est du vous dites trousser la
braguette d'un cadre qu'elle délice vous
faut du mec avec une cravate une légion
d'honneur un costume bleu
[Applaudissements]
trousser du cadre c'est vrai hein
pas du tout
donc si vous même chez vous être cadre
et un petit loup bourgeois et bien vous
m'évitez voilà
une philosophie de la vie Jenny vous
dites la vie est une mieux vaut
la sucer sinon elle te fait des misères
absolument
ça choque personne j'espère dans
l'assemblée
alors enfin tu vois pour te lever le
matin et tout ça j'ai pas je me fais
assis les mains particuliers dans la
tête
je prends
une politique pour tenir je vis avec
très peu d'argent etc j'essaye de je
suis comme ça et je me dis jusqu'à tant
que cette boule qui est devenue conne
d'ailleurs ce que mettons tout le monde
se met je crois que c'est effrayant mais
il y a pas que moi dans la misère mais
je dis après tout lève la tête il y a
pire que toi
[Musique]
jonquer mesdames messieurs
angélique vous ne serez pas étonné que
nous vous fassions une interview alerte
rose
[Musique]
bien est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pour aimer
vous avez besoin de quoi là
quel est pour vous le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte
la rue la rue c'est un trottoir c'est un
bordel un porche non la rue la rue
est-ce que vous préférez un homme qui
baise bien mais qui est infidèle ou un
homme qui baise mal mais qui est fidèle
moi je pense que je préfère un mec qui
baise bien mais qui est fidèle
on en parle jamais mais il y a des mecs
qui baisent mal et qui sont infidèles
aussi
est-ce que vous préférez être caressé
par quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu
par quelqu'un qui vous aime j'étais une
baleine échouée qui voudrait me caresser
est-ce que vous préférez
que votre mec fasse l'amour avec une
autre en pensant à vous ou face l'amour
avec vous en pensant à une autre
compensant une autre ouais
ça arrive ça c'est comme ça ça peut
arriver
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous préférez faire l'amour
avec 1000 mecs toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec de 1000 façons
différentes mille mecs alors là
c'est des questions
plutôt qu'un mec de mille façons
différentes
c'est plus sympa
j'ai mes emails il faut que je les
classe et tout
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu